going to ask
you God know everything correct God know
everything yeah God knows everything
yeah so if Jesus Is God he must know
everything yeah he does everything but
in the Bible Jesus doesn't know the hour
if you read Mark 13:32 Jesus said no one
knows that they in the hour but even the
in the Heaven nor the son but only the
father according to the Bible Jesus
doesn't know everything and you said is
not everything so who is wrong you or
Jesus that's a good point I understand
is there anyone greater than
God you just mov
now let's talk
about is plan of Islam for this nation
what's the plan of Islam Islam came to
save Mankind from the evil of this life
and evil the heref for example Islam we
have something
called English the corre translation is
a Divine Law okay that sh has different
aspects okay the most important aspect
in the teaching is to know your Creator
and worship him alone and to not worship
anything El beside him yes that's why
when we are speaking to you speak about
the most important thing which is
worshiping God Alone even according to
the Bible the first commandment is what
to know God and to love him all your
heart all right so these are most
important so I believe I respect I'm
want to disrespect you but I believe as
a Christian you don't worship true God
you worshiping someone besid God I
believe the same for you but I believe
one God how you same to me no I believe
the same because Muhammad basically saw
an angel which he was really a good
Angel he go he go start this he created
his all religion because he got from the
Jew he created all religion and he
self-proclaim himself as
a first Allah
how do you know was question so now how
do you know it was speaking to him I
told you how because when Muhammad came
with the Quran the Quran teaching he
said to them if this from me then you
are human beings like me and you are a
people of the language you are eloquent
in your poet and everything so if you
are in doubt I'm not prophet of God then
bring something like my book challenge
in the legislation prophecies and other
things which until our time no one is
able to challenge the Quran in ation and
it's even preservation like now give you
example in the Quran 1,400 years ago it
says that Allah will preserve the Quran
yeah now can we verify this claim yes if
the Jewish and the Christians and the
Muslims all of them burn all of them
decide to B the scripture the only
scripture will remain with us is the
Quran where in our hearts not not the
schoolers the Muslim children so we can
see that no way it's impossible for
someone to live in the middle of nowhere
1,400 years ago to come with this a
prophecy which we can OB it right now
and according to your Bible in
Deuteronomy 1920 I believe 18 something
it says how do you know a true prophet
he says if a prophet is in the name of
God and he come to pass is a true
Prophet so there's many prophecies
Prophet muhamed said and it's happening
right now according to your Bible he
must be true Prophet you true Prophet
who Muhammad get the Bible
then the Bible says Bible says actually
the Quran agrees that you need to follow
the teaching of the Gospel of Jesus
Christ and the Torah as well no the
Quran doesn't say that
if that
people follow the
Quran if the Quran is M mean the Quran
is a criteria over the previous
scriptures the Quran is a criteria how
the to follow the previous scriptures no
we believe yes the Quran tells us to
believe in the previous scriptures
you're right but not to follow it CU
those scriptures been obligated by
believing and following believe for
example I believe that God spoke to
Jesus in the what they call it like
teaching for example God for example God
said to Jesus to not fight at that time
I believe in that but have to follow it
because another Prophet came and agate
that teaching you understand for example
yes you're right for example you believe
you follow you believe Prophet Moses do
you believe Moses was the prophet of God
yes do you believe in the Old Testament
yes I do okay in the Old Testament set
to Stone the poate to kill a postate do
you follow it no so you don't believe in
it you don't believe in it everything
changes when Jesus came he gave us the
New Testament that's sh believe in it
doesn't mean you have to follow it yeah
that's my okay that was a good point
you're very good in talking do you get
paid for this no don't get yes I do
inallah hope by Allah
not after life and I want to ask so do
you born here or you born in Libya your
home
[Applause]
office back
back like
Italy you people you know about SI it
was under the Muslim empire for 10 years
I know that's why the
people you before like after you
still the mafia came in you know when he
came now I Algerian joking Algerian you
know to make me angry I look like but
yeah I want to tell you guys that Isa is
God he's not a
problem and also this is a Christian
Nation for
Christian Muslim it's not true
statistically you need to a Christian
country sayran country yeah like Dubai
is a Muslim country and there's many
non-muslims in Dubai Sai is a Muslim
country there's many non-muslims in Sai
understand so what is the problem
understand because the Christian country
because in the here in Britain let in
Britain you can disrespect Jesus but if
you disrespect gay people they put in
prison
yes disrespect Allah as well put Muslim
country no no no no no yes is a Muslim
country then ISL alhamdulillah what you
doing my country
country pleas to meet
you you know it's very hard to debate do
you agree it's very hard to debate with
him in apologetics okay I don't want to
do apolog I want to love people like God
does and are you married no I'm that's
why you talk about love too
much no no no I'm no gay I'm a Christian
and a
I follow Jesus and I will get married
one day but my friend my friend I want
to tell you this you know you have a
passion for God I can see that in your
eyes you have a passion for God and and
God God will will use you mightily for
his kingdom so when you go back in your
room tonight ask you know who is this
crazy guy talking about is Issa but
would be different because Issa will
speak to you tonight what we say to you
have advice when you go back home pray
say all good all the good Abraham the
god of Jesus the god of Muhammad guide
me to the truth are you going to say the
god of Jesus and God of Abraham you know
without any offense no no put mhammad
side now for the moment he's the prophet
of God say not but are you going to say
all pray say all the god of Abraham the
god of Moses I only pray to
Jesus we never B down so so the god of
Jesus God has Jesus has a God Jesus Is
God Jesus Is God but Jesus in the Bible
said I'm going to my God and your God to
my father your father he was showing us
the way how to reach if J is God that's
God pray to
anyone okay he came to to Mo to show us
how to walk with god with the spirit of
God so now God's going to show you how
he's going to pray he said oh God
forgive us talking about himself was
talking to his father yes so so who's
the true God the father or Jesus they
all the same of course the to God yeah
it doesn't make any sense go PR to God
think you're God that's what doesn't
make sense according to the Bible
according to the Bible the true God only
the father Jesus said the way so we can
see our respect you are going against
the teaching of Jesus you are you are
following the church you're not
following Jesus Jes okay it is God it is
God when Jesus said I have a god with
life speaking the truth when Jesus said
I'm going to my God and your God so
Jesus has a God so Jesus have a God he
his father does he have a God he is God
but how come he have a God have a God
Jesus God so Jesus have a god with speak
the truth he is God
Jus
said
jusus comes back you're going to believe
in him is God but he said it's not he
said look look what said the only true
God is the father that's what Jesus said
only the father Jus is God why don't you
believe in because Allah told us in the
Quran he said Jesus was God and his
mother they will not eat food because
that's not the nature of the most high
look to the this this rational Ral
argument in the Quran to refuse that
Jesus to be God but if it's God God is
self-sufficient but Jesus was in need of
food he cannot be the same God who have
but that's like a template you you just
repeat all the time no no I'm saying
it's a good template though no you
invest a lot of hours in no no because
it goes in line with our
found I can see you prep because he goes
in line with our intellect any person
with
lalal ask before you Isa is God that's
who said if you say Isa is God and Isa
said the only true God is the father who
speaking the
truth is God anyway so Jesus
ly want to pray for of God open your
eyes
seeus said true is the father he said
Isa is God so therefore according to ISA
was lying when he said the only true God
is the father may Allah guide his true
Tru
I I really like you thank you very
much
anyway the man